that's under a breaking story that
wearing out of Pakistan where supporters
of the ousted prime minister Imran Khan
have been arrested in Lahore
there were confrontations with police
officers ahead of Khan's planned
election rally but just hours before the
rally and authorities imposed a ban on
all demonstrations and last large
Gatherings which would last for a week
let's go live to Kamal Haider who can
explain all of this for us he's in
Lahore first of all Kamal tell us about
these arrests
thank you
when these party uh supporters were
preparing to go on a peaceful rally
because elections is less than two
months away in the province of Punjab
Imran Khan of course had announced that
he would be holding a peaceful rally
however all roads leading to his
residence in Zaman Park which is not
situated very far from where we are have
been blocked by shipping containers and
heavy contingents of anti-rise as well
as regular police now earlier there were
coupled with their supporters despite
the fact that Imran Khan had said that
this would be a peaceful rally to Mark
the beginning of the campaign the
election campaign so indeed the
situation quite dense we were able to
see a police prison Ranch taking away
dozens of supporters of the party who
were chanting in favor of their party
leader and the party the government of
course on the other hand and is
preventing this because they're afraid
of Imran Khan who has been scoring
political Victory after Victory and
although there are over 70 cases against
him which are seen as pressure tactics
he is he's remained determined and said
that he will continue that this is his
peaceful constitutional right so indeed
the government may be overreacting on
this this is after all a decision from
the Supreme Court that an election
should be held on the 30th of April
Imran Khan party supporter they've also
been told not to take the law into their
own hands they have warned that the
government may be using this as an
excuse to create a Law and Order
situation in order to postpone those
elections and all of this cabal after on
Sunday police failed to arrest Imran
Khan at his home in Lahore what happened
there
well the police had come from Islamabad
to serve him the summons from the court
there was of course speculation that he
would be arrested the Inspector General
of police of Islamabad also said that he
will be arrested however that the race
did not take place now today we are told
that another case has been filed in
baluchistan and this is regarding
imran's Imran Khan's criticism of the
powerful country's establishment which
of course is now being used against him
there is of course the freedom and the
right to speech Imran Khan of course is
being prevented from that according to
him and of course the fact that the
police are trying to use this as a
pressure tactic so the government
exerting maximum pressure in order to
discourage Imran Khan and is supported
but we've been told that the supporters
are coming through to Damon Park which
is not very far from where we are as I
mentioned and of because the police also
using heavy-handed tactics they're armed
with weapons as well as tear gas shares
and have been using water cannons there
are also some accusations that some
chemicals have been mixed into that
water in order to prevent people from
gathering in that area well it certainly
sounds like a story we need to keep an
eye on over the coming hours and we will
do so come off the moment thanks very
much